yes in reviewing classic movies I'd like
it to be for a movie starring John
Travolta samuel l.jackson uma Thurman
Harvey Keitel Tim Roth Amanda Plummer
Maria de Medeiros Ving Rhames Eric
Stoltz Rosanna Arquette Christopher
Walken and Bruce Willis Allenby written
and directed by Quentin Tarantino that'd
be a cool movie I'd like to see that
Pulp Fiction Pulp Fiction was the movie
that put Tarantino on the map as one of
the directors to look out for so pulp
fiction stars everyone I named in the
beginning of this video and what's it
about it's actually kind of tough it's
about a couple mobster hitmen and a mob
boss and a mob boss's wife and a boxer
and the pulp fiction by pulp fiction I
mean really well-written dialogue with
all these elements you think okay it's
like a mob movie with a lot of mob stuff
in action a few guns get fired but
that's not what drives the movie the
driving force behind this movie is the
dialogue that's right the philosophy
behind V for Vendetta is that words will
always retain their power no movie
illustrates this more than pulp fiction
if you love superbly written dialogue in
movies you will probably like pulp
fiction I think it's more than an
opinion at that point you like write
dialogue yeah here's pulp fiction Merry
Christmas now he saw Pulp Fiction a lot
in high school I didn't tell my mom that
I watched it a lot in high school but
the fact is I did one because she didn't
want me watching movies like pulp
fiction and two if she ever got curious
enough to watch it with me be like What
did he say he said bring out the [ __ ]
yeah it'd be stupidly awkward I wouldn't
want that now from the get-go in pulp
fiction you know exactly what movie
you're in for great dialogue a lot of
racial slurs a lot of shit's [ __ ] and
damn it's and the movie being obscurely
original and yeah I got to give it up to
Tarantino for that whenever you have a
movie that has a lot of racial slurs in
it and no one really gets pissed about
it good writing right there at most
someone's gonna be like I usually would
get mad but that was some good use of
that word right there and to top off
making this movie some original work
instead of running in chronological
order from start to finish the movies
chapters are all mixed up in a really
stylistic kind of way in fact half the
fun when you're done watching is going
all right so if that happened then and
this happened there this would have
happened first that would have happened
no that would have happened last because
there's still that it's just kind of
cool piece in the movie together after
the first time you watch it and the
characters are absurdly awesome to this
when you're like I think I've see
every character they're going to bring
on seen on others harvey keitel he plays
the wolf that dude is incredibly smooth
gonna be like that guy you know he's
he's alright john travolta and samuel
l.jackson man I would say they make this
movie as long as you know that they're
not the only ones who make the movie
gray 90% of the scenes in this movie are
great like so you can have random
dialogue you can be like I pick this
random piece of dialogue in Pulp Fiction
to be on my tombstone when I die I'll
probably be like yeah that's not a bad
pic after you see this movie you're
going to be quoting the living [ __ ] out
of it I remember my brother is high
school drama teacher she's like alright
everyone group together and play scenes
from movies at a point she was like no
more Pulp Fiction it's almost cheating
at this point you're all doing it
another thing that works about Pulp
Fiction is the soundtrack after you
watch Pulp Fiction you're going to have
all these songs in your head you're
gonna be like yeah I want to get the
soundtrack now and what you notice is
the soundtrack is really well edited to
the scenes of the movie like in the
whole bring out the [ __ ] scene the song
starts when they're going into the back
room and ends when the scene is done no
spoilers it's really hard to edit
something like that that the songs are
really catching yeah catch is always
good for me the only part the movie ever
really slows down for me is when Bruce
Willis and his girlfriend are hanging
out in the hotel talking it's almost a
direct contradiction to everything I've
built up about the dialogue just the one
scene for me where I'm like alright I'm
less interested and with the birth of a
great movie like Pulp Fiction comes the
inevitable afterbirth of all the Pulp
Fiction wannabes those movies that try
to have the dialogue carry the entire
movie but they come across as pointless
because they're just not written and
directed by someone who can do it's a
special kind of talent to make something
like this work and work this while
dialogue based movie that should be
extremely boring in this case it's just
not so great acting a great premise
great dialogue even proves that violence
can indeed be funny did you laugh when
Marvin got shot in the face raise your
hand if you laughed when Marvin got shot
in the face yeah exactly I laughed my
ass off because it was hilarious you
know I'm not a hipster I'll say it like
this
every hipster likes Pulp Fiction but not
everyone who likes Pulp Fiction is a
hipster there you go that's the tricky
wording right there Pulp Fiction
definitely is awesome tacular
and I do recognize that pulp fiction is
not for everybody if you watch pulp
fiction you're like I can't love it I'm
sorry it's just not my thing
I recognize that and I get it but if
you're kind of on the fence about pulp
fiction you're like yeah I love great
dialog and movies but I'm not sure if
I'll like pulp fiction I think you'll be
surprised at how much you actually dig
this movie so if you seen pulp fiction
what did you think of it what is your
favorite chapter in pulp fiction there
you go I'm going to ask you that
whatever it is comment below let me know
and as always if you like what you've
seen here and you want to see more click
right here to see more